okay
welcome everybody so we are um
here today lecture number 21 uh coming
into the home stretch of the course
uh i'd say probably
um this last quarter of the class of the
course is a bit more technical uh
perhaps so a little bit more abstract
some of the theorems are going to be
more difficult um so
i'll i'll try to work through them
slowly and answer your questions but uh
um
you know it's i think you can expect
them to find the material a bit more
challenging as we started uh
um
[Music]
uh
as we started um
um
you know with uh
this theorem last time uh
uh
uh
non-deterministic log space being closed
under complement so nl equals colonel
we kind of only got about part
maybe a third of the way through that so
i'm going to start over with that and
spend
kind of the first half of the lecture
today talking about that and then we're
going to talk about the
hierarchy theorems which are very
important um
uh aspect of the complexity landscape
basically they tell you
that if you allow
you know your favorite model let's say
turing machines to have more resources
then they can do more things
um but we'll get to that in due course
okay so let us
uh
go back
to oops reminder to myself
um
go back to
the immerman celeb cheney
uh which is that nl is
equal to co nl
um
so
as i mentioned these are going to be the
same slides as last time uh and i'll
just try to walk through them slowly
um i hope hope i hope you i hope you uh
get it but if you don't you know uh
ask me at the ta's questions
so we're gonna first i mean
the the the the i
the thing we're gonna show is that the
complement of path
is solvable in non-deterministic log
space we already know that path
is solvable in nl that's easy to do you
basically just
start at the start node
and you guess the sequence of nodes
storing only the current node in your
log space working memory
on the on your in your logs based work
tape
you guess the sequence of nodes
on the different branches of the
non-determinism and if you ever get to
the target node t then you can accept um
but how can a non-deterministic log
space machine know
or accept the complement of path so it
would have to accept when there's no
path
um and that uh is
a lot harder
but it's a big surprise to the
complexity community that it is it is
true
um
so as we uh discussed last time we're
going to talk about
computing functions with a
non-deterministic machine and that turns
out to be a convenient way of looking at
this
so we're going to have non-deterministic
machines
that have different branches of their
non-determinism you know on some input
and they're supposed to compute some
function value
you know remaining on the tape
but because of the non-determinism you
can't imagine that different branches
might have different function outputs
well that's not allowed
all branches must either report the
value of the function
um that we're trying to compute
or they can punt
basically they can reject
and say well you know uh
i i you know it's a basically i i don't
know
so all branches can must either report
the correct answer or they can say i
don't know and some branch must at least
one branch must report an answer
must report the answer
um for and that's what it means to be
computing a function
with a non-deterministic machine
and we're going to show that certain
functions can be computed with
non-deterministic log space machines
um
in particular this path function
which sort of
incorporates both the positive and
negative
of the pair both when there is a path
and when there is an is not a path
into into the function because the
function has to answer yes when there is
a path from s to t and no when there is
no path from s to t
okay so
if you could do this you're done
because
um you can make a non-deterministic you
could make an nl machine
so if you could compute the path
function you could make an nl machine
which would accept whenever the function
says no
um
and the other cases you know
and if
the um machine that's computing the
function
uh rejects you can then you'll reject as
well
but you accept if the function says no
and so therefore you're going to be
making a an nl machine which does the
complement of the path problem so it's
uh
you know
if you can compute the path function
that would be great
so that's what we would like to be able
to do
so as i mentioned we're going to have
two other values that that are going to
be relevant to computing the path
function which is what we're ultimately
going to do
and that's going to be the number of
nodes that you can reach from the start
uh
from the the start node
in your graph and the and then
for r is is the collection of nodes and
c is the number of reachable nodes
um
so shown on this picture and here i'm if
it's
helpful to you to see it in a more form
is
you
can think of r as a function of the
graph and the start node of course but
sometimes we'll just call it r you know
when it's clear which graph and start
node we're talking about
r is the set of reachable nodes so it's
the collection u
such that
the answer is
yes and
c
is the size of r
okay
so
the way we're going to start
is kind of an easy
theorem
though this is still going to be
relevant kind of at the end um but for
now it's really more a practice with the
concept that we have come up you know
this function concept that we've just
introduced so i want to say that
the path function
with an nl machine
then i can compute the count
uh
with an nl machine
okay so understand what computing the
path function means
that you have your nl machine
and
um
every branch has to either say i don't
know which is reject or it has to have
the answer which in it's going to be yes
if there is a path and know if there is
no path
and if i can do
be able to count the number of nodes
that do have a path
the number of notes for which the answer
is yes
and this
i think if you're comfortable with the
definition
this is
[Music]
more or less obvious
because
what you would do
is you would go through the nodes of g
one by one
and test uh
using your path function
uh what the answer is
yes or no
and every time it's a yes you add one to
the count until you've gone through all
of the nodes
and then um
you have your answer which is nodes
that's c
now if the machine
that's
trying to compute the path function on
the non-determinism rejects that that's
okay you'll
computing c that branch will reject also
but when you're um some branch
has to get the right answer on the on uh
you know for it has to get the right
answer
um and so then you get the
you know
you know what's happening with that
node and so you then um
can either increment the count or you
move on to the next node i think i'm
uh
trying to say
i'm not sure if i'm making any clear by
kind of repeating myself but okay here
so you're going to start out with the
you're given the
the graph and the start node
we're trying to compute this value c
which is the number rechargeable from
the start node
you start out with you you have a
counter which you're going to set
initially to zero and you go through
every node of the graph
and if uh
the path function computation says yes
you can reach you then you add one to
the count it says no you cannot reach
you then you just continue
um
and uh
maybe i should add another line here if
if the
you know if the if the the thing that's
computing
uh rejects then you also reject um
and then at the end you output
um
so what we're going to prove is the
other direction if i give you the count
then i can answer
the question for each node whether it's
reachable or not and this is the thing
because what it's saying that is i can
give you the count i'm done
if we can get that count that's going to
be enough
um
okay so
maybe even before the check-in maybe we
should just answer any questions because
you know if if you're
stuck here then you then you're doomed
um so i think it's you it makes sense to
try to understand what's going on at
this at this
um because i think the real the real
guts of this proof is coming on the next
slide um they're
kind of the main idea so i'm happy to
take
if there's any questions about this
i'll just wait for a second to see if
you're typing away
there well why don't we go to the
check-in maybe that'll help um
not a very difficult check-in
um
it'll come up
okay just a little practice with the
concept
so
i'm getting going to give you some graph
it has nine nodes
um and i want to know the value of the
count
um
so we'll we'll assume that s
the start node here is reachable from
itself
and now what's the value of c
okay
are we
good gonna shut this down give you
another two seconds please get your
answer in
okay
uh ready set end
yeah the right answer is in fact
uh e which is six there are six
reachable nodes in this graph and that's
what the value c is supposed to tell you
is how many nodes can i get to from s
okay and what i'm saying is that if i
can calculate that
in this sort of non-deterministic
function sense so if it's so some
branches can get that answer
um
then i can use that to
test for each node
whether it's reachable or not which is
kind of a little bit of a miracle
right that's kind of surprising just
knowing how many nodes are reachable
will allow me to test whether each
individual node is reachable
um because that's there's no obvious
reason why that would be
so there's uh going to be a procedure
for doing that which is on the next
slide and here it is
um
okay so this is the key idea that we're
going to repeat
um uh
later but
so
it's good to understand um
this is this is the slide you really
need to understand
uh
okay so i'm given the graph let's assume
the graph has m nodes
um
now as i said
okay so let's just say what what are we
doing here
given that count we can compute path
so we'll get the answer for every node
in the graph
if i just know
how many you know so i'll know i can get
the answer for which
whether a node is reachable or not
if i just have if i just know how many
reachable nodes there are
um so what i'm going to do is get get
that count of how many are reachable
now i'm going to go through
um
i'm going to because let's see what's
the idea here uh before we even jump
into the algorithm
the idea is
let's say i know how many nodes are
reachable like 100 nodes are reachable
now what i'm going to do what the
algorithm is going to do is find all
hundred reachable nodes
it's got one by one but it doesn't
matter sort of conceptually it's going
to find all reachable all reachable
nodes
and non-deterministically guessing them
so it's not sure in advance which ones
they are but it's going to guess
basically a hundred no it's going to
guess some of the nodes as being
reachable
confirm that the ones that guest are
reachable are reachable and then check
to see that that number equals 100.
on some branch of the non-determinism
you will guess right and you'll end up
with exactly the right set of 100
reachable nodes and then you'll see
is t
one of those reachable ones um in which
case you say yes or is t not one what is
not one of those hundred nodes
and then um you know the answer is no
because if you've guessed a hundred
nodes and you know they're all reachable
and you know there are exactly 100
reachable nodes then every other node is
not reachable
so that's kind of that's the spirit of
this and that's i'm just going to write
that down here on in the algorithm
can you guys hear me still
somebody said my audio is like blipping
out
i am getting a sign or two of unstable
internet so you know uh if if you need
me to repeat anything just just send me
a note good thank you
okay um
all right so well uh oh maybe i should
speak slowly if it's
not coming through too well
okay
um
so
so what we're going to do is go through
eat all the nodes of the graph one by
one
and guess whether it's a reachable node
or not a reachable node
if we guess it is reachable
i'm going to also guess the path which
shows that it's reachable
and then
i'm gonna and i'm gonna keep a count of
how many reachable nodes i found
if that count agrees with the value c
um i started with
then i know i found them all
and if t is not one of them
then i know t is not reachable
that's the idea
okay so
here's my this is going to be a count of
the number of nodes that i have found
which are reachable
um that's k
now here i'm going i'm going to
non-deterministically choose is it a
reachable node or not
i've just called it
two branches of the algorithm the p
branch or the n branch p means there's a
path
and n means there's no path
so if i guessed p at this point for this
node u so i'm going through each of the
nodes one by one each and u is the
current node
if i've guessed that
it's it is it does have a path from s
then i'm going to
uh guess that path to make sure that it
really is a reachable note
um
if i fail to find a path then this is
one of the branches of the
non-determinism
that is going to fail it's going to punt
it's going to say i don't know under
this branch um
because either
you guessed wrong and this node was not
reachable
or if it was reachable you guessed you
you failed to find a path which shows
you that it's reachable there was some
path but you didn't guess the right one
um either way you made a bad choice
you're gonna you're just gonna punt
now
if you have determined that t is uh um
that node that you've just shown is
reachable because at this stage you did
not fail so you succeeded in showing a
path to
um
then um
uh
and u equals t then you know t is
reachable that so there is a path from s
to t and you're finished
that you know you've got the answer
you're looking for and so now you can
say yes
otherwise if t is some if you is some
other node then you can just increase
your count of the number of reachable
nodes that you found
okay so you've found a reachable node
if it's t you're great you're done if
it's not you just include that as your
in your account of reachable nodes um
now if you've guessed that the node is
not reachable okay then you just proceed
you know you
you're not gonna
you're just gonna move on to the next
note because you're looking for a
collection of reachable notes
um
okay uh i'm getting some questions here
but let me let me wait till the end here
um now
after i finished going through all of
the nodes
so i'm finished with this uh um this
loop here of going through all the nodes
um
now i see did i find
c reachable nodes because k is the count
of the nodes that i've found to be
reachable if that
agrees with c then i know i found them
all if it differs from c
then something has gone wrong
because i am told there are c reachable
nodes and i did not find c reachable
nodes
so i made some bad guess along the way i
guess some node which really is
reachable
i guess it was not reachable so i didn't
find them all
i'm gonna punt
um but if i found them all
and so and and i didn't end up accepting
it it didn't say yes at this stage so t
was not one of the ones i found a
reachable then i then i
uh i'm convinced that t is not one of
those that are reachable that was not
one of those c nodes that i found which
are reachable and now i can say no
okay so let me let me take
questions here uh because i think we're
yeah that's the end of this slide this
is this is the kind of
an important
uh
piece to understand
we can spend a couple of minutes trying
to work through this
uh
so somebody's asking how does
non-deterministically pick a path fail
it if you fail
um
what i mean is pick a path from s to u
so you have to go from s to whatever
your current node u is
so you're going to pick some path
to u
you guessed u is reachable now you have
to demonstrate it's reachable by picking
a path from s to you if you don't end up
at u
um
and the pair you don't want to go
forever on any branch so you're going to
limit it to m steps your path has to be
of length m at most
so after m
steps if you have not reached you by
that point you've picked a bad path
and you're going to reject
um
okay uh
okay so what's the difference between
know and reject that's a good question
um
reject in this case is an i don't know
the algorithm
uh could not make a determination based
on the guesses that it's made
in this non-deterministic branch of the
algorithm it made bad choices which
doesn't allow it to reach a conclusion
one way or the other
okay
remember this algorithm here is
computing a function now
it's not a now it cannot deterministic
algorithm in the language recognition
sense this is a function computer and so
it has to get the answer to the path
function which is a yes or no or i don't
know on some branches or some branches
that's allowed to do that too
so no and reject are totally different
um
okay
okay this is the same thing we talked
about last time why do we need two
branches for p and n um
if we're only going to have
proposal just to have the p branch
well but some nodes are not reachable
if you're gonna look for
if you're gonna you know
if you have a an unreachable node
so it's not an r
you can't get to that node from s
you have to skip over that note
because you're trying to find a subset
of the reachable nodes
so you're trying to pick that subset
here um one note at a time
so if you're only going to allow things
you're going to require everything in
this subset there are going to be some
nodes which are not reachable and you're
not going to find a path because they're
not reachable and you're going to end up
projecting all the time
you know on that node so you're going to
be this the algorithm will will it will
not will not work
um
okay so i'm not sure i understand this
question here but somebody says if t is
reachable we output yes on that branch
but don't we also output no
on some other branch
let's that's that's a good cool let's
see what happens
if it's
if t is actually reachable
um
how can we up so if t is reachable
there's some branch that's going to
output yes we all agree with that
at least if you're following we agree
but
how could some other branch output no
if t actually is reachable
because that's a great question
um and no that's not going to happen
uh
if t is actually reachable how could a
branch output no
um
[Music]
that must mean
that it does not guess
t as one of the reachable nodes because
it's going through all of the nodes here
um you know it's going to all the nodes
and it's picking them as reachable or
not
if it pick t is one of the reachable
ones then it's going to output yes
because it will find you know it'll
either output yes or if it doesn't find
the right doesn't guess the right path
it'll end up rejecting on that uh on
that path but some path will will end up
saying yes so if t is reachable
and
uh if you guess if you know t is
reachable and you guess t
you know you guess u is reachable one at
the point when u equals t you will end
up outputting s
the only way you could not
not
output yes is if you guess that node is
unreachable
but then your count is not going to add
up right
because you you wouldn't you did not
find all the reachable nodes if t is one
of the reachable nodes and you know
there are 100 reachable nodes
and you skipped over t as one of the
ones that you say is unreachable you at
best can only find 99 reachable nodes
and and you're not going to end up
saying no you're going to end up
projecting
so it's a very good question but you
have to think through what's going to
happen here that's
this c here is kind of a check
it's almost like you know um
uh
well in
it's like a checksum if you know what it
is it's so it makes sure that everything
that you if you got to see
if you got the if
if k equals c at this point that means
you actually found all the reachable
nodes so c is kind of a check
that you found all the reachable nodes
um
right so
if k equals c at this point you have
found every reachable node
and if t was one of the ones that are
reachable you found t
uh
okay let's see
um
is the reason we do this with c
essentially so that we know and we can
stop guessing and correctly identify if
it's impossible to reach t
well it's not a matter of it it's not a
matter of stopping guessing it's it's
it's a
it's a check that we found everything
because we're going to go through
and do all the guessing for every node
no matter what
so we're not going to stop anything
early unless we find that t is reachable
then then we can stop early but if to
show that t is not reachable we have to
go through the whole process
um
how can we intuitively see that we don't
have contradictory branches that's sort
of i was trying to say that just now i
don't know i i hope that got through
you can't have contradictory branches
because if you got to this stage here
you have found all the reachable
nodes so you've at this stage if you got
to six
you have made all correct guesses
you have found all the reachable nodes
you have convinced yourself that they're
all reachable um by
guessing the pairs to them and you've
checked that you have the right number
of reachable nodes because it equals c
so you must have found them all
so you cannot have a contradictory
answer because either t was one of the
ones you found in which case you would
have already said yes
or otherwise you found them all and t
was not one of them and so you're going
to say no you can't have both both
things cannot happen okay let's move on
so the next thing we're going to do is
the next slide is exactly the same as
this slide
except instead of saying
is um
is t reachable i want to know is it
reachable within d but within distance d
okay so um
which is going to mean exactly the same
procedure can i get
uh
instead of asking can i get
um
um
uh
from s to t
with a path of any length of course it's
going to be most length m now i want to
know can i get to it from s to t by a
path of most length d
these are number of edges in the path
say
um
and uh
that's the same procedure because
instead of i'm just going to cut things
off at
a d
but if i if i if i know in advance how
many nodes are reachable within d
um
i'm going to find all the nodes that are
reachable within d and c was t one of
the ones reachable within d
it's the same exact idea so here here is
the next slide which kind of shows that
uh so here here's the definitions
path sub d means reachable
by a path of length of most d
okay so um
r sub d is all of the ones that are
reachable
by a path of that length
and c sub d is the count it's a number
that are reachable uh within d
um so if you understood the last slide
hopefully this slide will seem kind of
obvious to you i'm gonna just highlight
all the changes
so if i can now calculate
c sub d which is the number reachable by
a path at most of length d
then i can test whether or not nodes are
reachable by a path without length
first i calculate c sub d
i go i pick every node as being
reachable within d or not
now i just have to check that my path
that i'm guessing has a length of most d
instead of length at most m which is
what i had before
keep a count of the ones that i found if
that count
equals c sub d then i know i found them
all if it's not equal to c sub d
then uh i've made some bad choice along
the way and i can just punt and say i
don't know
um
and if t was not one of the ones that
i've shown to be reachable within d
then i know it's not reachable within d
and so um
uh i can say no
okay so i don't know if this merits any
additional questions um but this is
really the same
it's just a repeat of the previous slide
what's kind of amazing
is now
the last slide
is
going to be again a repeat
uh let me just let me just force out of
where we're going but feel free to ask a
question on this or on the first slide
if you didn't on the previous slide if
you didn't get that um also we can try
to help you out with that
um
the next slide what i'm going to do
is show
how to compute
all these c values
and i should mention um
the value c which is the total number
reachable is going to be the same as c
sub m
reachable with an m the number of nodes
of the graph so if i can get up to c sub
m i'm done
um
and what i'm gonna show you is that
uh
knowing c sub i i can compute c sub i
plus one or c sub d i can compute c sub
d plus one
since i'm using d as my index here
basically
so c sub zero we know is just s well r
you know it's just one because you can
read just
start with s that's the only thing
reachable with zero
and then once i
know that i can fi figure out c sub 1 c
sub 2 c sub 3 and so on and then i get
the c sub n and then i have the count of
the total number reachable and then i
can test the path function
um
okay so the trick now is being able to
count
uh
given c sub d i would like to figure out
what is c sub d plus one
now how am i going to do that what i'm
going to do
is that's my goal what i'm going to do
is
something in between
i'm going to do a theorem just like this
but instead of
given c sub d instead of computing paths
of d i'm going to compute paths of d
plus 1.
so
knowing
how many are reachable from d
i'm going to give a test for whether
things are reachable within d plus one
and the fact is that's easy
because this thing already tells me how
to compute whether i'm reachable within
d
and being able to be reachable from
within d plus one means i have an edge
from something that's reachable within d
so if i can figure out which are
reachable within d
well and i just want to say do i have an
edge
you know
uh
do i have an edge from from one of the
nodes that are reachable within d then
i'm reachable within d plus one
then if i can test whether individual
nodes are reachable within d plus one i
can count
how many nodes are reachable within d
plus one that was that very first easy
theorem that i showed
so i know there's a lot of pieces here
that you have to put together but in the
end each p each individual piece is not
that bad
um
okay i don't know how many of you have
followed me oh no this is not supposed
to be here uh
there we go
so here is the last part
which again is just a simple
modification of what what the previous
slide had
so
i'm going to show how to compute
the path d plus 1 function so testing if
there's a path of length d plus 1 from s
to some node t
but only knowing how many nodes are
reachable within d
so i'm going to find all nodes that are
reachable within d
just like i did before but see if any
one of those nodes has an edge
to t
not necessarily that one is equal to t
because that says that t is reachable
within d but i want to know does it have
an edge to t that means t is reachable
within d plus one
so if i find all the nodes that are
reachable within d
and t turns out to be reachable from one
of those with it by an edge
then t is reachable within d uh d plus
one
and if d is not reachable from any of
those nodes with an edge then t is not
reachable when d plus one
i hope you're following me i'm not sure
you are uh
so anyway that's the that's the
algorithm here and
uh
uh the corollary is that you can compute
c sub d plus one from c sub d because if
you can count the path you if you can
test for each node if it's reachable as
i mentioned before you go through all
the nodes see whether the reachable and
d plus
d plus one and then
count them up
now i have c sub d plus one and now i'm
done
because
uh
uh
i'm gonna
compute each d plus one from the from
the value d that i previously computed
i'm going to do that from for all these
should say zero here actually um
and except
uh if the path says if this if the path
function now says there's no that the
answer is no
because i'm trying to do
you know the complement of the path
language
and reject of the path uh thing for m
says yes
and that's my non-deterministic
algorithm for the path
complement
uh problem
anyway
maybe you need to look at a little bit
offline um
it's presented in a little bit different
way in the book uh i don't know if that
will be more or less clear to you but i
kind of i think this has been a little
bit more unpacked for the purposes of
the lecture
um
so let's just see do we i'm not getting
any questions which probably means
uh
uh i've lost a huge chunk of you um but
uh the good news is we're gonna move on
to a different topic
so
um
but feel free to ask a question on this
if you want
or we're going to shift gears now to
talking about the hierarchy theorems
which is going to be the second half of
the lecture
also not so easy i have to say
probably a little less technical than
this one is but
it's also this are going to be
um spending time on just mainly just one
theorem
but anyway so looking ahead to what
where we're going and then we'll have a
break
um
we uh
well what we've shown so far
these are the major complexity classes
i'm not not including let's say the the
complementary classes the co-np uh type
classes um
these are the major complex classes
we've seen so far
and as we've seen they form a hierarchy
of containments
some of those containments trivial and
some slightly less trivial
but we have not shown whether any of
these classes are different
you know we've pointed out that there
are some unsolved problems here but do
we know any of these classes differ from
each other
or could it all collapse down to l
and the answer to that is
we do know that p space and l are
actually different
that we can prove
and it's a um
it relies on the theorem
that says if you give a
turing machine more space
then you can do more things
so because p space
is much is a bigger bound than log space
we know we can do more things
in fact
because
n l is contained within
log squared space deterministically and
p space is bigger than that we actually
can separate p space and nm
so we're going to prove that today
um so the basically the idea of the
theorem says that if you give a turing
machine
a bit more time or a bit more space then
it can do more
though you have there are some
conditions on that that we have to uh
we'll get into
one of the conclusions that we'll show
is that
um
time n squared if you compare with time
it's you know the time com the things
you can do in n squared time uh versus
the things you can do in cube time there
are more things you can do in n-cube
time then you can what you can do with
n-square time i mean that's what you
would expect
um but
it's not the case that everything we
expect in uh complexity theory we can
prove this is one of the things we can
prove
so as you add more time you can do more
things so this is a proper subset here
so there's there are some things in time
n cubed that are not in time n squared
and ditto for space
okay um
so that's going to be
that brings us to our
coffee break
and so feel free to shoot me any
questions about
what we've done so far or anything else
and otherwise
we will um
launch our timer and i'll see you in
five minutes
okay so i get getting some good
questions here could we also make a
solution this is getting back to that um
um
uh
um
the logs the nl equals coin l somebody's
saying could we just
um make another selection just by
non-deterministically choosing c
vertices
and then not and then checking that
they're all reachable
that's effectively what we're doing
but
be careful that we because we cannot
store c vertices
so that's why we're doing them one at a
time
we can't guess all c vertices up front
because where you're going to store all
that we only have log space
okay another so maybe somebody's asking
how much working space do we need for
storing the intermediate steps i'm not
sure what intermediate steps you mean
but if it's all the ci values
you know see
going from c0 to c1 to c2 to c3 we don't
store those
we all you need you need c sub d
to calculate c sub d plus one and then
you forget c sub d you couldn't store
all the c values but you don't need them
all you only need the most recent one to
go to the next one okay somebody's
asking can i go over why the complement
of path in nl
implies nl equal coin l
because the complement of path
is
uh essentially it's co n l complete i
mean l it is um
so
everything in nl is reducible to path
the
everything in cohen l
is reducible to the complement of path
by the same reduction
um and so if you can do the complement
of path in any uh class you can do all
of the complements of nl languages in
any class and so you can do the
complement of path in nl you can do all
the
connell problems in out in
nl and so then nl equals comma now
you have to you have to just think
through the logic of it this is not that
that part is not hard um
why it's enough to solve the path
complement problem in nl that does
everything else because it's a good so
the same completeness phenomenon that
we've been seeing
okay somebody's asking about the the two
sat problem that we talked about last
time um and is it um
and you know i i pointed out that that's
in
nl the you know the the two side problem
well the complement of the two set
problem
uh
you know the unsatisfiable two set
formulas that that's an nl language
because you can basically look for a
contradiction uh non-deterministically
in log space
um
that's
i think i probably won't be able to
explain that in a minute but maybe we'll
have our recitation instructors cover
that in recitation
um it's a nice proof not very hard but
it's it's an it's a nice proof
it's it's it's it's it's you know it's
not
it's something you have to do you have
to think about you you have to argue but
it's still it's not super hard um
understanding the two sad problem and
you know the complement of two set we
showed is in nl
and because nl equals coin l also the
two sat problem itself without
complementation is in nl
and in fact is nl complete
okay
um
i think we're going to have to move on
uh i'll stick around after lecture in
cases any questions that i can answer
quickly at that point
sorry if i couldn't get to your question
just now
all right
continuing on here
okay
shifting gears the space hierarchy
theorem
so
um
so as i mentioned i think um
uh maybe it's good to just go back
to this slide here um
we're going to do the time and space
hierarchy theorems which show that if
you can do a little bit more if you give
a little bit more time or a little bit
more space you can do more things
we're going to do the space
case
first because that actually tends to be
slightly
for certain technical reasons slightly
easier
so
uh
space hierarchy theorem so here is
the statement of the theorem and
it says for any bound
think of s is going to be some
you know
space bound
and again
f has to satisfy some technical
condition in yellow remember that it's
yellow because that's going to be
relevant later
um
uh so there's going to be some technical
condition
um
for no matter what function you you have
whatever space bound you have as long as
it satisfies this condition which is a
mild condition but you need it uh
whatever space bound you have um you can
find a language a
which requires exactly that much space
so if f is like n cubed we're going to
find a language a that requires n cubed
space if it's n to the hundredth we can
find the language that requires into the
100th space
and cannot be done within 1999 space
whatever it is
you can find a language that requires
exactly that much space and if you like
it a little bit more formally so that
means that it can be decided in that
much space
but it cannot be decided in less space
okay
framing it in a slightly different way
in terms of our space classes
um i'm going to define a notion which is
you know kind of it's not
it's
not said this way in the book but maybe
it's a helpful way to write it down
it's space little o of f of n
so those are all the things that you can
do by a function that's little o of f of
n
in space
so space little o of f n is properly
contained within space f of n
in other words there's something here
which is not in there
okay picture pictorially
i'm going to exhibit some language some
explicit language a
which i can do in this much space but
not in any less
now you know you can sort of think of
this as a little bit like the situation
for context-free languages and regular
languages where we exhibited a
particular language that differentiated
that was it context-free but not regular
and we're going to kind of do the same
thing now
but the one key difference is that in
the case of separating the context free
and the regular we could give a nice
language like 0 to the k1 to the k
here the language is not going to be so
nice to describe
it's going to be the language that some
turing machine we're going to give
decides
but you're not going to be able to get a
nice simple understanding of a it's
going to be whatever that turing machine
does and so in that sense it's not a
very natural language um that's easy to
sort of get your mind around um
so the i outline and really you don't
have to
worry about this but maybe it helps it's
really going to be a kind of a
diagonalization proof
um
the way this machine d
um is going to operate so d is going to
give you my language a
um
so d is going to be designed and i'm
going to show you d on the next slide
uh d is going to run within my target
space bound f of n
and here's the key here's the kicker
d is going to be designed to make sure
that its language cannot be done in less
space
and the way it does that
is it makes sure that its language is
different from any language that
that is um
decidable by a turing machine in in less
space and it's going to be different in
at least one place
so any
d is going to guarantee that its
language cannot be done in little o of f
of n space because it's going to be
different from every language that's
doable in little o of f of n space
somewhere
okay that's the point and then the
language a is going to be
the language of this
uh turing machine d
okay so it looks like a tall order the d
has to make sure that each
you know that that for every machine
its language differs
uh from that machine's language if that
machine is running in little of f event
space
but it's basically going to be a
diagonalization
so
for all of the different possible inputs
to d
that input is going to actually code up
a machine
uh on which
we're going to make sure that we're
different from that machine if it's a
small space machine
okay
let's see
so i can take a couple of questions here
does f have to be computable so that's
going to be one of the conditions um
that we're going to have to guarantee
where f satisfies the technical
condition yeah it's going to end up
being half it's going to be computable
but that's not enough
um
good question though
uh
okay so let's let's
let's move on from there okay now
so here is now what's what my job is to
give you this turing machine d
so d
these language is going to be my my
language a which i can which requires f
of n space cannot be done unless
okay oops i need to
i need the full slide here so i have to
take myself out
um
[Music]
all right uh now
this is my goal i want to exhibit this
language a which i can do in this much
space but not in any less
and
so i'm going to give this machine d as i
mentioned where a is d's language
d runs in order f event space and that
sort of that achieves this part
and d it makes sure that its language
cannot be done
in any less space
so that achieves this part
so it's different from the language of
any machine that runs in little o event
f of n space
okay um
[Music]
so uh
this is how d is gonna work
okay i'm gonna try to give you a little
picture uh to help help see the to
accompany the description
uh so d
gets its input w which is of length n
the very first thing d does
is it marks off
f of n's space
because it's only allowed to use
we're only going to allow d to use f of
n space because otherwise we're in
danger of
d
not
of a not being in in space f of n so d
is going to guarantee that by making
sure
it's going to mark off f of n space
and if it ever tries to use more than
that it just rejects
and but
by virtue of that we're sure that these
language is in space f of n because d is
an f of n space turing machine and it's
going to be the side
okay so
this part
so far is not too hard
okay now we're going to start getting
into the meat here
so
if w
um
now what we want to think of w as a
description of a machine that we're
going to feed that's that's going to run
on w so this is going to a little bit
you know
back to an earlier when we talked about
diagonalization so don't get
thrown off by this um
we if
we're going to think of w not only as
the input to d but it's also going to be
the description of a machine
and if it turns out that w is doesn't
describe anything it's just a jump w
then we're not not interested we're
gonna we're just gonna reject on that w
we're only interested in the w's that do
describe some machine m
okay
so if m
if w
uh describes some machine m
then we're gonna run m on w
and we're going to do the do the
opposite of what uh what m does
that's the whole idea
we're just going to uh make sure that
what we're doing is not the same as what
emma's doing
so at a high level
the the basic idea for this
is is not hard um
so we're going to simulate m on w
if m x rejects then we'll accept and if
m accepts then we'll reject we're just
going to do the opposite
um
and i think that is
so we have to be careful when we do the
simulation this is a little bit of a
detail but you know
this is a proof where you need to pay
attention to some details
um
the cost of simulating
m
on d
is only a constant factor
um because if m uses a certain amount of
space
when d is simulating m you know m may
have a larger tape alphabet than d does
but these can then encode um m's tape by
using several cells for each of m's
cells but it's only going to be a
constant factor and that's important
here because
um we have to make sure that
you know if this was a big blow up um d
would not be able to run m
um
i i think i'm sort of arguing the
details without making sure we
understand the fundamental concept um so
let me back up
the point is that d is doing something
the opposite of
m now
uh d can't be different from every m
because d itself is a turing machine of
course but but the thing is is that
d is only running within f of n tape
cells so it has to be able to do that
simulation of m within that amount of
tape if m is using a lot of tape then d
is going to use a lot of tape and it's
just going to reject
so this is only going to really come
into play
getting being able to simulate m if m is
using a small amount of using a small
amount of space so that d can do the
simulation
okay so let's just see maybe
uh
so they're going to be some issues here
but before i get to that let's just see
what uh what your questions are
how can a turing machine know if w is
encoding some other turing machine
no that's simple
you know what what is a coding of a
turing machine it's just you know the
standard we have a standard coding um
it's just you know coding the rules of
the machine so it has to have states
transition function blah blah blah so it
just has to be some you know whatever
our encoding for the turing machine is
we can always test whether
a string is a legitimate encoding of a
turing machine so that that shouldn't be
bad um
somebody says why do we reject if we use
more than f n cells isn't it okay to use
order f of n
yes it could be but
we have to cut it off somewhere
you know
it might be it's okay we could use two f
of n we could use 10 f of n but we have
to have some constant for d
and let's just kind of simply constant
one so d has to run within f of n cells
um and that's going to guaran that's
going to be good enough for us
okay do we have to make sure that m runs
a little of f of n so we can't really
tell
whether m is running in little o of f of
n
or we can tell us whether we can finish
the simulation
so that's actually going to be
maybe you can just hold off on that
question because there is a point that
we have to follow up on in that which is
um
uh just because
you know we may or may not be able to
finish simulating m
on this w
doesn't necessarily tell us what the
asymptotic behavior of m is but we'll
have to look at that in a bit okay so
somebody's saying what happens if m
loops on w that's going to be one of our
issues we have to deal with that's a
good question there step two alone can
use them more than f of n cells
yeah step two alone can use more than f
of n cells if it does we're just going
to end up projecting
okay so we're getting good questions
here some of them we're going to which
i'm going to address anyway so why don't
we just move on um
okay
so here is sort of a question i think
this is one of the questions that that
related to one of the ones that got
asked what happens if it runs in little
of f of n space so we we remember what
we're trying to do is be different from
every small space you know little o of f
of n space machine
so what if m runs a little o of f of n
space but has a big constant so what i
mean by that concretely is suppose d is
an n cubed space so suppose we're trying
to
get a
in in cubed space
but show what's not in n squared space
d is going to run an n cubed
and what and we have to make sure that
any machine that's running in n squared
space cannot do the same language
um so we're going to be different from
that but the problem is that uh in
uh
the machine m
might be running in
n squared space but with a huge constant
so it might be running in a million n
squared so that's still a machine that's
running in
a little o
of n cubed and we have to be different
from it but for the particular w we're
working on we might not have enough
space to run m because of the huge
constant it that con
the asymptotic behavior is only going to
be relevant well for large w for smaller
b we may not see that we may not have
enough space to run m so
um
what are we going to do to fix that
we're going to run that m on infinitely
many different w so it's going to be
infinitely many different w's
that are all going to encode the same m
and the way i'm going to do that
is by
uh
thinking of w as representing m
but having
an unbounded number of trailing zeros
after that
so i'm going to strip off the very first
thing i'm going to do with w is i'm
going to strip off the trailing zeros up
into the final one i'm going to remove
those
and then take the rest
and as the description of the machine
so now i'm going to have potentially
w's that have an enormous number of
zeros at the end
big enough so that i can see the
asymptotic behavior of m
and that if m is really running in
little o of f of n space i'll have
enough space to run m to completion on w
and so then i'll be able to be different
from it
okay
um
so i'm kind of showing that over here so
here's a very large w
i'm going to strip off the trailing
zeros
the rest of it is just going to be m and
i'm going to run this m on the whole w
the entire w without the zero stripped
off so now m is going to be running on a
very large input
um
big enough so that d uh d which has
asymptotically more space than m does
will have enough space to run empty
completion
um
now another question that got asked what
happens if m loops
that's going to be a problem because d
always has to hold
and if it just blindly simulates m
then d might be looping on m
none of m is going to use a lot of space
by the way
because then d is going to catch it in
step one but if m uses
his loops on a small amount of space
then uh d
might end up looping as
presently constructed so what i'm going
to do
is i'm going to put a counter which
makes it stop if it runs for
2 to the f of n space so basically
because that's how long d could possibly
run without looping anyway
m could be running without looping
anyway and so we're going to run it for
this amount of
this number of steps and
uh i'm going to reject if it hasn't yet
halted as well as uh that because it has
to be looping at that point anyway um
and so it's not interesting for us
it doesn't matter what we're going to do
if it hasn't halted because
m is not a decider
and the last thing is how to compute f
um
so i'll try to address some questions
here in in our remaining time
uh how to compute f
so to mark off f of n cells we also have
to compute f i didn't think anybody any
of you guys asked that question except
maybe sort of the very beginning about f
being a computable function
certainly f is going to have to be
computable but not only does it have to
be computable it has to be computable
within the space bound
and that's just going to be a condition
we're going to impose on f it's so
called space constructable namely that
you can compute it within its own space
bound
and all nice functions that we care
about are going to be space
constructable
so
it's not doesn't turn out to be
an obstacle to applying
uh the hierarchy theorem but it is a
condition that we need it actually is
not true without that condition
um
okay let's let's just oh this i have a
check in here maybe we can take a couple
of questions first
some of you are anticipating my check-in
actually which is good um
so let me hold off on those
sorry a bit confused about what is m
can we say d as input m and simulate m
on yeah so
uh somebody's saying
can we say that d has input m
and simulates m on itself yes that's
exactly what's happening the reason why
we're doing that is because we have to
cover all possible m's
so as we get all possible inputs w
they're going to range over all possible
ends and so every possible m is going to
get addressed to see if we can run it um
within the space bound and be different
from it
d's job is to be different from each of
those ends
but it's not you know again there were
some details here that got raised in
these issues um
but in a sense this is just kind of
more technical
i would focus on understanding what i
originally wrote down because that's the
main idea the rest of it is just kind of
implementation details
okay so why don't i
can i give an example of a non-space
constructable function
yes
log log log n space you cannot compute
log log log n space within log log log n
space
and in fact it's known
that
there's nothing new
between constant space which is just
regular and log log log n space anything
you can do in log log log n space is a
regular language
so the the hierarchy theorem doesn't
doesn't won't apply there because well
it applies but that's not a it doesn't
well you know it's not it's not space
constructible
to find
higher level um you know large
um
non-space constructable functions you
can do it but they're
you know you you
they're not easy to describe
okay let's do our check in here
what happens when we run dion itself i
got a couple of people asking me about
that so that's a this is just a good
lead into our check-in and this a little
you really have to understand what's
going on
to see what does d do
when if you feed in itself maybe with
some trailing zeros because remember the
algorithm strips off trailing zero so
what is what does it do in that case um
so here are my
options there you can get to pick which
ones which one
you uh you think is the answer so i'll
give you another 30 seconds on this
because this requires a little bit of
thinking
if you want to invest in it all right
i'm wrapping this up guys
five seconds to go
okay i'm gonna end it so get your
participation points in
a bunch of you have not uh said anything
come on
um i can see the count here and it's
there's a
three or four of you are not not
answered well you're going to lose out
closing
all right so the right answer is in fact
c it does reject let's just understand
what happened is definitely we don't get
a contradiction i mean this is an
algorithm i just described it's going to
do something
um
uh
i'm assuming the people who picked e are
having fun as i did when i came up with
the check-in but um
uh not a question answer a doesn't is
not going to be good either because d
has to be a decider so it can't loop on
anything so the only sort of reasonable
answers are accept or reject
when you run d on itself
uh
what's it going to try to do
it's going to the very first thing it's
going to you know mark off f of n tape
cells
and then it's going to get its input
which is itself
tries to simulate itself on the same
input
that uh simulated d is also going to try
to mark off f of n tape cells
but um due to some simulation you know
there's going to be some cost to doing
the stimulation when the simulated d is
going to try to mark off f of n tape
cells it's going to blow
the original d
space bound and exceed the bound and so
d is going to reject up right in step
one
when it tries to get an input of its of
itself
so that's um
it's very clear what's gonna happen in
this it's just gonna reject
because of the for this reject this
reject in particular
and notice this would you know yeah
you know
okay let me not try to confuse it um
okay so that's that's that's all i want
to say about this um let's now move in
our remaining seven minutes to the time
hierarchy theorem which is very has the
same proof um but some of the technical
details are slightly different
okay um
so now if i give you a time bound again
we you have gonna have a face with the
same notion that you have to be able to
compute f within f's amount of time
so it has to be a time constructable i'm
not gonna define that um
so there's a language a which requires
that much time
um so it has to be decidable within that
much time but there's a slight
difference here and there's and this is
an artifact of the proof of the theorem
not because it's an absolute truth as
far as we know
uh it's not that it's not decidable
little o of f n you actually you can
only prove something slightly weaker
when you have one tape turing machines
that it's little decidable little o over
there's there's a slight um
uh
gap in what you can prove so it's not
only that you can't prove you it
requires little o but little o of
little of f of n over log f of n
is uh what you can prove that the you
get from this uh time hierarchy theorem
but let's not get caught up on that for
now um
uh
okay
so the proof outline is the same outline
as we had before um
uh
we're going to give a d that runs in
order f of n time
so it's
ensures that the language is in that uh
time complexity class time f of n
and it makes sure it's different from
every machine that runs faster
by some significant love by a log factor
faster
okay and so um why don't i
uh
show how that goes
um
the proof is in some ways
almost exactly the same
um
i'm going to give a d
which runs this much time
and it shows it's different from every
m that runs in
a lot less time
here is the algorithm for d
now it computes f n but it does
something a little different with f of n
remember in the space
hierarchy theorem
we marked off f of n space
now this f event is going to be used for
a different purpose it's going to be a
clock
and you have to shut m down
if it runs for more than f of n steps
not if it uses more than f of n space
because we're only interested in m's
that use
significantly less
than f of n time
so we're going to run an m you know for
f for some number of steps
whatever m says we're going to do the
opposite and only if we can actually
finish that simulation we'll be be able
to be sure that we're different from
what m is doing
um so this is the whole algorithm here
we don't have to do any further
modifications
and where's that login factor coming
from
it's actually coming from a funny place
um
and and you know you have to get into
the little bit of the guts of this
when you're simulating m on w
remember that m itself was described by
w
so you're going to have to write down a
copy of m
which is you know just
as described by w
and then so you're gonna and then you're
gonna have the tape that am is working
on
which is starting out with w on it
um
and uh
you have to be now you have to be a
little careful how you manage that
because if your description of m is just
sitting at the beginning of the tape
as you're simulating m
every time you do one step and modifying
the tape
you don't want to have to go back
to the beginning of the tape to look up
the next step of m
so you actually have to carry m along
with you
as you're doing the simulation
and you can do that by expanding the
tape alphabet of the tape
so that you can effectively have two
symbols
on
one cell one is going to be
for describing m and the other one is
going to be for just the for m's
for the simulation tape
and you'll be carrying m along with you
uh wherever your head is
so you don't have to go very far to look
up m
and
so that's all possible because that's
going to add only a constant factor
because m is fixed in size doesn't
depend on
you know
you know
for large inputs to m m is fixed
but the tricky thing here is
the counter to make sure we're not using
too much time
um
[Music]
the counter has size log f of n because
that's how big it has to count up to so
you should you can shut it down if it's
going to exceed the f of n steps
um
and
because you know you have to
run for a certain amount of time
and
carrying the keeping the counter nearby
has the counter now could be pretty big
and so that's going to cost you a log
factor of um
of simulation cost
to
move that counter around all the time
and so
that's why you have to
run for only a log factor less
so that you can actually finish within f
of n time as you're as you're required
to do
okay i realize that that's a mouthful
there and you may not have all
understood that
it doesn't matter it's not that critical
i think what i'm really more concerned
is you understand the the main idea of
the um the hierarchy theorem some of
these implementation details
you know you
if you don't get them
i wouldn't worry about it i i feel i
have to include them for completeness
sake and to be honest with you about the
proof but if you didn't follow
everything that's okay i do want to
understand the main idea though of the
algorithm
making sure that what it's doing is
different from what every machine is
doing if that machine runs in little o
of f of n space or or a small amount of
time you know little o of f n over log f
of n time
okay so and i think we're gonna uh
we're gonna end here so come pretty much
out of time uh i'm gonna stick around
for a little bit
um
in case there's any questions here oh
wait there's one let's check in though
um
let's let's look at this this is kind of
an interesting sort of follow-on to the
hierarchy theorem um if you look at the
two questions does l equal p and does p
equal p space
these are both unsolved problems
does the what if anything does the
hierarchy theorem tell us about those
questions
and it's kind of interesting that there
actually does well i'll leave it to you
to
uh
tell me if you can see what what it
might actually be telling you closing
get your answer in
okay one two three
i feel like i'm running an auction house
here
i should have a gavel
okay
yes in fact we know that you know these
are separated so it's not even though we
don't know if l equals p or p equals p
space they can't both be equal
because then um l would equal p space
and we know that's false
um
so at least one of these has the answer
no
okay so with that let's wrap up today's
lecture
you know we prove these hierarchy
theorems and why don't we just uh
um
i'm going to
uh
shut us down here but but before well
we're over so you can feel free to go um
but i'll stick around in case anybody's
any questions for a few minutes anyway
um and then uh
we'll call it a day
since we just showed space and is a
proper subset of space n to the k for
any k why can't we also say
space n is a proper subset of p space
yes space n is a proper subset of p
space
yeah so somebody just asked we just
showed that space n is a proper subset
of space n to the
k does that also say that space n is a
proper subset of p space definitely
any
um
space n to the k is a proper subset of
space n to the k plus one
which is a subset of p space so any
fixed polynomial is going to be a subset
of p space because p space includes all
the polynomials
which of the two unsolved problems
uh whoops
do i think is more likely likely to be
true
well
i think most
i mean i would bet that both of these
are not equal so both of these have
answered no
um
uh it would be weird you know
i mean you think l equals p
that anything you can do in polynomial
time you end with log space log space is
incredibly weak
and and p space is incredibly strong
um
i would be shocked if either of these
were equal
so we just
the problem is that we don't have a
method
for proving
um
problems
are are actually
have high complexity of of any sort we
don't know how to show things outside of
l don't know how to show things
outside of p
except by using the hierarchy theorem
diagonalization is the only method that
we have for showing things or outside of
classes
and there's reason to believe that as
we'll this will get to i think next
lecture in fact
there's kind of reasons to believe that
the hierarchy theorem type argument
which is diagonalization is not going to
answer those kinds of questions um so we
need a different method and
diagonalization is all we got
good question though
if i didn't get to answer your question
you have a question for me ask it again
because it's got buried
so it means we are very far from
disproving p versus np is that right
it could happen tomorrow
you know how do you how do you how can
you tell it doesn't you know it it seems
clear
that the present state of mathematics as
of right now
is
you know we don't have a clue
how to answer those kinds of questions
and it's not obvious that we've even
made any progress
um but
you know
that's the nature of the game that's the
nature of the beast
you know somebody gets a good idea and
all of a sudden lots of things uh can
change
and that can happen and then in any
point maybe one of you guys
when were these results first
this is the the stuff okay the hierarchy
theorem is old
that goes back to the very when time
when time classes were first defined i
think is one of the first results to
show the hierarchy
and
that's
late 60s
the
nl equal coen l i think i mentioned was
like mid 1980s
much later
i mean from your points of view it was a
bit it was back in the
cave
cave age uh either way but uh yeah but
but the the hierarchy team that that's
actually pre predates uh
my coming into the field but but the but
the nl equal conel that was something
that i was
i personally experienced how surprised
people were
okay i think i'm gonna
send you off all off on your way good
good having you here and i have a good
weekend everybody
and um
i will see you on tuesday
bye
you